man I found my red shirt but I used to
have a gray hoodie I can't find it dunno
where it is it's gonna have the red
shirt gray hoodie blazer it's gonna have
some pretty solid low-key cosplay I
can't find the hoodies supposed to point
that kind of burns anyhow Dogma so dog
most one of the Kevin Smith movies from
the view askew Cinematic Universe came
out in 1999 which is actually the view
askew universe is really my earliest
memory of a cinematic universe so Jay
and Silent Bob strike back first and
people were like dude you haven't seen
the other oh my god so we all just grab
it hold it back in the day and by and
large I really loved the movie so docma
is the story of a woman named Bethany
played by Linda Fiorentino she has a
crisis of faith but the voice of God
played by Alan Rickman comes to her and
he's like you need to go to New Jersey
and stop two angels Loki and Bartleby
played by Matt Damon and Ben Affleck you
have to stop them from basically going
into this church and unmaking existence
so she sets off with a fellowship a
fellowship of two prophets played by Jay
and Silent Bob the 13th apostle played
by Chris Rock so basically it's
fellowship with the ring with stoners or
fellowship of the ring with stoners
again finally apologists I know I've had
a good time if you're drunk as a writing
for 10 years no one cares have the
boring mind-altering drug alcohol as
part of your writing no one's gonna care
your reference weed this part of your
writing a couple of people in the
comments section lose their minds but I
wanted to revisit dogma after watching
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot because I
was like is it nostalgia goggles to
Kevin Smith really have it back in the
day or is it just like a thing that's a
thing I could enjoy back when and I've
grown past it or gotten old and boring
who knows what happens point is I
watched Dogma and it's still great I
don't know what to say I watched it
today also I watched it not under the
influence of anything because that's
proper science you got to be fair if I
watched Jay and Silent Bob reboot sober
I got to watch this sober that's just
consistency first of all everyone brings
in this movie I love the characters and
the actors how they portrayed them
whether it's the lead Linda Fiorentino
she was great in the movie as someone
who's vulnerable with a crisis of faith
she doesn't know if she's the one to be
doing this thing but also she doesn't
take any [ __ ] from Jay cuz the entire
time Jay is being Jay about it which
I'll get to him in a second as to why
he's perfect in the dynamic he plays in
here
well done story of discovery and growth
with her she's great in this movie she
actually has one good meltdown scene
where you're like I get where you're
coming from
also Alan Rickman as the Metatron the
voice of God I don't know if it's the
fact that Alan Rickman is the one
playing this role just Alan Rickman in
this role along with Chris Rock Jay and
Silent Bob just there's this element of
irreverence in these biblical characters
that other wise and other forms of media
would be like we're perfect we are
apostles after all my Lord be it his
name we have to do this question this
mission for the sake of humanity because
we are perfection is if I think about
the story of the Apostles I would like
to think of them as more flawed as I
remember them being in the Bible flawed
apostles hanging out with Jeremy Sisto
Jesus uh-huh I like that so when you
have the voice of God getting doused
with a fire extinguisher because you
know flames and burning bush and all
that he's all like just cracks me up and
Kevin Smith in this movie did what I
think Kevin Smith was trying to do in
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot we just
have your lowbrow humor with Jay and
Silent Bob but also on the flipside have
those really heartfelt character moments
in here in my review the Jay and Silent
Bob reboot I talked about how he has a
couple feet in a couple different
generations and hands in different pots
and he's trying to go with different
tones that just don't work but it's like
everything that was a critique there he
did make work in Dogma Kevin Smith has
the stoner humor in this movie that he's
known for but you don't have to be
stoned in order to enjoy it it has that
for teenage stoners who want to watch
Dogma and just enjoy it for that but
then he has deeper philosophical
ideologies and emotional moments in this
movie that resonate with you as you get
older it's a movie that can span
generations I thought it was really
clever the way he brought religion into
it but even philosophically speaking I
like when Chris Rock in this movie plays
the 13th apostle who was taken out of
the Bible I like how he talks about the
problem with the faction of religions
because you have all these religions me
like no no we're the only that like the
other ones are fine but we're the
correct one and it's not really what God
would want I enjoy that perspective it
makes everyone just kind of self reflect
and be like yeah maybe maybe they're all
flawed right and also the chained Silent
Bob element worked very well in this
movie I don't know in fact that you have
good versus evil heaven and how
and then in the middle of it as an
apostle as someone who's on the
pilgrimage of good you have Jay this
loudmouth foul-mouthed stoner hedonist
but he's on the good guys side clearly
he's smoking the devil's lettuce he must
be on the bad just he's human and Jay
cracks me up so much in Dogma as opposed
to the Jay and Silent Bob reboot partly
because I think his dialogue is better
in here and less pathetic because he's a
person this age doing it not that age
doing it we had a point you're like well
I'm not like that but I'm laughing at
the fact that you are and one day you'll
learn he's in his 20s she was supposed
to be young and stupid in your twenties
and then when that character is 40
something it's time to hang it up Jay's
just a character who's supposed to be
that age in that age range and then when
that character grows up you just retire
him so Jay works in this movie as he
worked back then in his optimal age
range but really for me the point of the
movie the big scene stealers Ben Affleck
Matt Damon as Bartleby and Loki I love
the dynamic of the two I love the story
that they're just these two angels who
were thrown out of heaven they have
found a loophole to get back into heaven
by doing that they're gonna and make all
of existence but they don't know that
they don't know the consequences of
their actions they're just trying to go
home they're not trying to be dicks and
although I liked the pair Ben Affleck I
gotta give props Bartleby it's been a
mixing role for Ben Affleck I mean yeah
logistically he's done roles in which he
was better in them sure doesn't change
the fact that when I think of a great
role that Ben Affleck played Bartleby
comes in my mind and his rant that he
has in that parking garage with Loki you
just feel the pent-up pain and anger
that he has against his father and
creator just threw him out of his house
where was this infinite [ __ ] patience
Affleck was bringing it in his movie
didn't have to it's a STONER comedy but
it wasn't treated like one or at least
it wasn't treated like that's all the
movie was there's more going on in Dogma
absolutely it's one of those cases like
I'm not a religious person grew up a
religious person but not a religious
person in this phase in my life but I
understand why people are religious but
I generally appreciate the approach
Dogma takes when it comes to religion
what I mean it does poke at religion it
puts the multi-billion dollar industry
known as religion in the crosshairs sure
but it doesn't the name of challenging a
power structure it raises the question
that maybe these structures are flawed
structures made by flawed people and
maybe the little dogmatic rules they've
come up with to keep that power
structure in play maybe that doesn't
matter
maybe if there's a God God wouldn't give
a [ __ ] about any of that I always got
the feeling that the movie dogma put
religion in the crosshairs but not the
religious the movie seems to leave the
people out of it and leave people to
believe in a God if they need to or want
to believe in a God at most is saying
yeah belief in God is fine but if maybe
if you trim some of the fat
I just appreciate the fact that the
movie doesn't go out of its way to
insult people who might believe in a
higher power
Indian dogma was a great surprise turned
it on I was like oh god please be good
please still be good and I watched it
and it was still good it was great even
I would argue I really liked Dogma back
in the day I appreciated it more now
it's the movie that aged very well for
me it's a movie that was made by Kevin
Smith from a place of passion and the
Jay and Silent Bob reboot there's a
monologue at the end of the movie or
near the end of the movie where you feel
like Kevin Smith's basically telling his
perspective and I thought it was very
sweet it was it was a great monologue
for sure the monologue is like when you
have kids you're no longer the star of
the show you're the stage and you
basically do what you do so your kids
can have the best shot possible in that
Jay and Silent Bob reboot I feel like he
made so his daughter can have a
spotlight shown on her and I totally get
that is he's being a good dad about it I
respect it but when he made movies that
came from his place of passion to tell
his story that's still when he made his
best work that's how art is and that's
what Dogma is to me it's it's absolutely
it's a piece of Kevin Smith art I will
say Dogma is definitely worth watching
definitely worth buying on blu-ray just
funny cuz I guess it's really hard to
find doesn't exist on any streaming
platforms and the hard copies I guess
you can find a DVD in a used bin or the
blu-ray Andy used Ben if you find the
blu-ray of Dogma buy it it goes for like
a hundred bucks online it's something to
do with a Weinstein Company anyhow I
hope it gets released
alright so Dogma have you seen it what
did you think about it have you seen it
recently does it hold up is it better
now that you
remember it before does it not hold up
whatever you think a dog from a comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
whether it's Linda food whether it's our
lead Linda fruit whether it's the lead
Linda Fiorentino
whether it's the lead Linda Fiorentino
yeah I'm editing right there for some
reason I can't jump into a sentence
after stating the name like it locks my
brain up